you should get the orange soda it's
amazing okay what would you ladies like
to drink orange soda please I'll have
the strawberry soda Kourtney Kardashian
and her kiddos poke bun at Keeping Up
with the Kardashians on Tick Tock me too
strawberry soda
I am so shocked and betrayed right now
court and two of her three kids
ten-year-old Penelope and eight-year-old
Reign shared that clip to tick tock on
Monday doing a dramatic reenactment of
this AI parody of the family's former
reality show I can't believe you guys
did that did what you didn't order the
orange soda we changed our minds Kim
what would you ladies like to drink
orange soda please I'll have the
strawberry soda but they aren't the only
stars to get in on the trend I mean it's
a beautiful thing Sabrina Carpenter used
the sound you should get the orange soda
it's amazing so did Addison Ray I'll
have the strawberry soda and check out
the stars of Riverdale Lily Reinhardt
Camilla Mendes and Madeleine pesh
putting their acting chops to the test
I'll have the strawberry soda
thank you
me too strawberry soda but back to the
Kardashians I am so shocked and betrayed
right now this is hardly the first time
the famous fam has poked fun at
themselves on social media it's really
fun to see last month Kim's daughter
North mocked her mom on Tick Tock lip
syncing to a mashup of the skims
Founder's most memorable quotes
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot that's
northie rocking a bleach blonde wig to
match her mama's current hairdo and
caution tape to Twin with Kim's famous
Balenciaga outfit and she trolls the
scene where Kim's ugly cry meme was born
you don't think I feel bad I feel
she also takes a dig at the moment Kim
lost her earring in the ocean
back in 2020 Kylie Jenner and her BFF
stassi acted out that scene too my
diamond earring came up and the oh the
ocean and it's gone
and that was just the beginning it's fun
the besties reenacted a whole bunch of
iconic keeping up moments do I look fat
just like 20 pounds overweight this is
the land of your people this is not the
land and if you thought Kylie's sister
Kendall and her famous mama joke Kris
Jenner were spared from the mockery
think again those are cute jeans you're
cute jeans those are mine no yeah they
recreated that moment too those are my
jeans no then when these are cute jeans
and remember when Court dropped this
one-liner about the process of freezing
her eggs I just cry myself to sleep
every night well court has a little fun
at her own expense bringing back that
moment with the help of her friend
Addison Ray
I mean I feel fine I just cry myself to
sleep every night and Court's daughter
Penelope she followed suit I mean I feel
fine I just cry myself to sleep every
night so whether it's a lost diamond in
the ocean a meme worthy cry face or
crying yourself to sleep it's safe to
say this is a family who doesn't take
themselves too seriously you should get
the orange soda it's amazing okay what
would you ladies like to drink
[Music]